I often get asked by Young acting
students in high school and college how
do you do it where how can I uh you know
Libra and I go shortcut you look for the
shortcut yeah yeah yeah
like a drug ah give me the shortcake
there's no shortcut sorry that's what a
a real love of acting is it's a
relationship it's not a fling
it is committing to something for the
rest of your life
when I think of acting and I think of
creating and writing I mean it it
occupies all of me and I love it
if I ever start to complain about having
to go to work at six o'clock in the
morning or not wanting to do anything I
don't want to do that
then that's the sign I've I've lost
the flame and it's time to hang it up